do you remember the days when a lot of
people turned their nose up
at putting content on youtube a lot of
times people
thought they're so funny yeah so the
whole youtube thing has
i mean i think what youtube started in
or 2006 or something like the first
youtube video went up
and then slowly like we got around like
oh no you can actually make
like they started monetizing it and
putting ads and you can actually build a
following
and make a living and then for like the
last
you know for like that first maybe 10
years
it was kind of like this stigmatized
thing of like oh if you can't make it as
an actor you could do parody videos on
youtube or like what does youtube know
but now when you look at it some of the
most
skillful you know camera operators or
like
uh storytellers are on youtube and they
have figured this out years ago and they
have built up this audience and now you
have you want to know what sells movies
it's not the rock it's not his acting
skills
it's his ability to like motivate
followers i mean this guy every time i
look at his instagram he's got another
10 million subscribers i don't even know
what he's at now i mean 150 million
subscribers on instagram
so like motivating them to go see your
movie
fast and furious 19 or whatever it is
like that's real power
that is real like that is the future
that we're going down
and so how do you do that i mean and you
can definitely do that in youtube and
these youtube creators
they may have been laughed at years ago
when it was first starting out
but they are holding all the cards now
they
have everything and it all has to do
with
letting people in showing them what you
can do
um being humble uh
building a core audience of people that
will follow you anywhere and they'll go
watch your movie or or
go visit your body of work or your your
art or whatever it may be
i want to read a comment that someone
left on our channel and um
it uses a dirty word which is uh the i
word
influencer and so that's a dirty word
in some circles it is so the the comment
and i'm paraphrasing is
the world doesn't need any more
influencers slash youtubers slash
filmmakers
what the world needs is more teachers
engineers social workers etc
what are your thoughts i mean so
youtubers are teachers and if you think
about it this way they're actually being
paid
what teachers should be paid so like the
whole university
scheme or like public education scheme
of what we have of how
we have people that should be regarded
as our highest esteemed
profession these are the people that are
that are teaching our children of what
to learn how to be
how to how to act in a public arena
and yet they're making 30 000 a year or
they're
they're making so little that they
they check out when they're doing their
work so they're not really good at what
they do
right or they're just not suited for the
job they're not passionate i mean we've
all had a teacher who's passionate
like my family is a line of teachers my
dad's a teacher my mom's a teacher my
aunt's a teacher my uncle's a teacher
so many teachers they're all passionate
about what they teach
and the best teachers i've had we're
always passionate about that as well and
so that really comes across
and i think you have youtubers who uh
now not all youtubers and not all
influencers but if you are genuinely
passionate about what you're talking
about that is going to
drive home much much
easier into your viewers heads
than someone that's just doing it for
money or for views or for
whatever reasons people do it for i mean
i do understand that
the i their influencer does get a bad
rep and that's mostly because of
instagram i think yeah
the idea of like going to these exotic
places and
photographing you hanging out of a
helicopter door with your shoes on with
a pretty girl
and in reality that's not you know
that's
like maybe a hundredth of what that
experience
actually was like it like shies away
from the whole
it's just that part definitely gets a
bad rep
for influencers but you know youtubers i
think
the ones that are like actually teaching
something i think they have
they know they know their worth they
know that it's they're not the same
as like a lifestyle instagram
vlogger yeah that's just trying to
flex all the time i don't know
you